Prof: All right,
so I'm going to finish talking
about overlapping generations
today.
I'm going to defer my plan to
save Social Security till a
couple of lectures from now,
and I'm going to start to
introduce uncertainty in this
class.
The exam will only cover the
stuff up to basically the last
problem set.
There are a few things about
overlapping generations I might
say today,
which will clarify what you
already know,
but you don't have to know
anything beyond the problem you
turned in on Thursday--
you're turning in today.
So you I think are better
informed now than you were
yesterday.
I think it's a big help to be
doing the problems,
so for those of you watching on
screen at home,
do the problems.
So remember we had a situation
where there were generations,
each of whom was rich when
young and poor when old,
that looked like that.
And it went on forever.
That was the only difference
from what we've had before.
People's lives were shorter
than the lifetime of the
economy,
and to go to the extreme,
the economy goes on forever,
even though people only live
two periods.
And then there was land,
1,1, 1,1.
There's land,
and then there's
generation--because I forgot the
generation--here's generation 0,
generation 1,
generation 2,
generation 3...
and time.
This is time.
And here's time 1,
time 2, time 3,
time 4, time 5,
etc.
Now this model,
I've been told,
is the hardest thing you do the
entire class.
Things are going to get much
more complicated,
but since they build up slowly,
I think this model's the
hardest thing you have to do the
entire class.
I realize it's a little bit
confusing, but in the end,
I don't think it's that
complicated.
And it reveals all the subtlety
of Fisher's thinking,
not that Fisher understood
about overlapping generations,
but his ideas,
you can see here.
So what are his ideas?
You've got a complicated model
in which you've got people
trading apples when they're
young, against land.
So the objects in the economy
are land, which you're supposed
to think of as the stock market,
okay, so we've got land and
we've got apples.
Now what's interesting is,
the land is going to constantly
change hands.
So the young here are going to
buy the land,
but when they get old,
they're going to sell the land.
So the land is constantly
changing hands.
It's not that one person buys
it at the beginning and holds it
forever.
So Fisher's formula,
remember, was that the price of
any asset was going to be equal
to the discounted dividends.
And the logic seemed to be at
the time that the price,
you know, if the person was
going to buy the asset,
that they could take the money
now or they could wait and get
all the dividends in the future,
and they would compare what
they would get out of the
dividends in the future to what
they have to give up today.
But you see,
in this example,
it's a little more complicated.
Nobody's going to hold the land
and get all the dividends.
Each person who buys the land
knows that he's going to sell it
long before getting all the
dividends from that land.
And yet the price of the land
is still given by this formula,
so we never use the fact,
in Fisher's argument,
that the same person had to
hold the asset till the end.
And so now we have a case,
an extreme case,
where people only hold the
asset for one period.
It's always turning over,
turning over,
but still the price of the
asset is equal to the discounted
dividends.
So the secret to solving this
problem, according to Fisher is,
forget about the asset.
That makes it too complicated.
Fisher's argument again is,
take financial equilibrium--
maybe I should write it on a
different board--
Fisher's argument is,
financial equilibrium,
equilibrium, okay.
Get rid of assets.
Put dividends into endowments,
and transform it into general
equilibrium,
the very thing you saw within
the first couple days of class,
okay, and then go backwards and
figure out what the financial
equilibrium is.
So although it seemed very easy
before, it's a little subtler
this time, but it's the same
principle.
Whose endowment should you put
the dividends into?
The land is changing hands all
the time.
There's a new guy owning it,
a new guy owning it every
period,
so whose endowments do we
increase when we put the
dividends of the land into
someone's endowment?
You put it into the endowment
of the guy who owned it first.
So put dividends into
endowments of original owners,
okay?
So this old person who has the
right to the first apple,
his own endowment of an apple,
and also the right to the first
dividend,
but he actually has a right to
all the dividends.
So his endowment,
the endowment of Mr.
0 is going to be 2,1,
1,1, etc.
Because he has his original
apple, plus he's got--he has his
endowment of an apple,
because everyone when they're
old has an apple.
He's also, because he's owned
the land before,
gotten the right to this first
dividend of the apple,
that's 2, and because he's the
original owner of land,
he owns all the future dividend
streams of the land.
So we can forget about land
after we've stuck the dividends
into the right person's
endowment, and now we just trade
as if it's general equilibrium.
We just look for supply and
demand and the present value
prices, which are p_1,
p_2,
p_3,
etc., okay?
And because it's symmetric,
we know that this is going to
equal 1--
p--we can always make one of
them be--
one price can be 1,
so the present value prices are
going to look like this.
The reason I can make this
simplification is by symmetry.
Every generation is the same,
so it's obvious that I'll be
able to keep repeating the same
argument over and over again.
Okay, and so what do I have--so
remember, the land has
disappeared here.
Even though this generation is
buying the land and selling the
land, in Fisher's story,
you don't have to pay attention
to that.
This guy bought the land,
and then he sold the land,
so it was a fair trade.
So he started without it and
ended without it.
The fact that in between he
used the land to save,
you can already do that in a
general equilibrium.
You don't need to think about
the land,
because the only reason this
guy is buying the land is to use
it for a means of saving,
which is already in Fisher's
equation.
So to solve for equilibrium is
then quite simple.
We just, in every generation,
we look at--
remember, I forgot to write the
utility functions,
so we have U of consumption
when young and old is 1 half log
young [consumption]
1 half log old [consumption].
Okay, and so therefore,
in equilibrium,
we have to have that 1 half
times the income of every
generation--
every generation's going to
have 3 when young 1 when old.
Now from the point of view of
any generation t,
the prices are p,
say, p_2 when young
and p_3 when old.
Now remember,
any generation cares only about
relative prices.
So I can call them
p_2 or p_3,
or I can call them 1 and p,
because the ratio's going to be
p.
So, much simpler to think of
the prices as 1 and p.
So the old guy,
if I'm doing any t,
like this period 4,
the old guy here,
you know, that's p_4
and p_3.
He cares about p_3
and p_4.
But he only cares about the
ratio of p_3 and
p_4,
which is p.
So from his point of view,
he might as well have thought
of them as 1 and p.
So his income is 3 1p,
and he's going to spend half
his income on that good,
which for him is a relative
price of p.
The young guy is going to spend
half his income,
which is also 3 1p.
This is the relative price
between t - 1 and t.
between t and t 1.
But he's now young,
so his price when young is 1,
and that has to = 3 1 1 =-- so
I wrote it as 1 3 1 = 5,
okay?
And we solved that,
and we found that p = .55.
So are there any questions
about how we did that?
That's where we ended the last
lecture.
Is that clear to everyone?
Yes.
Student:
>
Prof: Okay.
If I didn't have symmetry,
I would have to say this is--
I would have to write this--in
general,
this would be 3p_t-1
1p_t over
p_t,
and this guy would be
3p_t 1 p_t
1,
divided by p_t.
Right?
That would be,
in general, if I had prices,
the present value prices,
this guy's income would be
given by that,
because he's the old at time t,
and the young would be given by
that,
okay?
And I'd have to do this,
a new equation,
for every t.
Who asked?
You asked the question,
so does that make sense?
Student: Yes.
Prof: Okay,
but I have to do that for every
single t,
so I have an infinite number of
prices and an infinite number of
equations.
But then you say to yourself,
"Well,
hmm, if I take the ratio of
p_t over
p_t-1,
to = p, then the ratio of these
two prices is the same as this
price," and so I'll have
one equation and one unknown
variable,
and that same equation will get
repeated every other generation.
Because when I go to generation
s,
which is another generation,
all that matters is the ratio
between p_t-1 and
p_t,
and p_t and p_t
1.
So if I assume those ratios are
always the same,
I'm going to be repeating the
same equation over and over
again.
So if I can solve it once,
I can solve it an infinite
number of times.
It's basically the same
equation written infinitely
often,
and so as long as I stick
in--keep these ratios constant,
I'm just doing it over and over
again,
so I only have to do it once.
So it doesn't have to work out
that it's--it's just because
every generation has the same
endowments and every generation
has the same utility.
That's why it's such a simple
thing to solve.
Yeah?
Student:
With the regular p,
before you erased it,
is that a weight thrust that
becomes the old
>
because we assume young age
>?
Prof: The p,
this p, is just the ratio
between--this is how I got p.
p_t--okay,
p is p_t over
p_t-1,
which also = p_t 1
over p_t.
The ratio of all the prices is
always p.
The ratio between time t and
time t 1, this good is more
valuable than that good.
This good is only worth p.
p is .55.
It's only worth 55 percent of
this good.
And then this good here is only
worth 55 percent of that good.
So the symmetry assumption,
the symmetry of the problem
suggests that I could guess that
the prices are--
the present value prices are
going to decline by the same
percentage every period.
Okay, any other questions?
We'll keep going with questions.
Yes?
Student:
Could you explain the e^(0) =
2,1, 1,1?
Prof: Yeah,
what is the endowment of the
original old guy?
He's the guy who owns the land.
So what does he have?
He has one apple,
his endowment when he's old,
like everybody else who's old.
He has an apple,
his own tree in his back yard
gives him an apple when he's
old,
or when he's an old man or an
old woman,
he can barely scrape together
one apple.
Now he also has the land.
The land is his for all time,
so the land is paying an apple
every year forever.
So his own apple,
at time 1, plus the land's
apples is this 2,
and the land produces an apple
every time in the future.
So that's his endowment.
I stuck the dividends of the
land into his endowment.
Student:
>
like he lives forever,
or >?
Prof: Right,
I'm not assuming he lives
forever.
He doesn't.
In fact, he knows he's going to
die in period 1.
He wants to do all his
consuming in period 1,
but he hasn't--that's another
subtle thing about this.
You can own endowments that
occur after you're dead.
If you own a tree,
the tree, the land is going to
be producing stuff long after
you're dead,
so when you sell off the land,
you're selling off those future
dividends.
Of course, you're not going to
hold the land.
If you don't care about your
children,
you're not going to hold the
land beyond the time you live,
because you want to just
consume as much as you can.
So you're going to sell off the
land and consume,
but you're selling off all
these future dividends,
okay?
So another thing this model
gives us is a new argument for
the real interest rate,
real r, being greater than 0.
So why is it?
Because from this
formula--gosh,
I was so clever.
Where did I--oh, here.
From the price of the asset,
this discounted dividends,
that's going to be 1 over (1
r), 1 over (1 r) squared,
1 over (1 r) cubed,
..., by the way,
that's = to p p squared p
cubed, you notice,
okay?
So the discounted value of the
dividends is the price of land.
So the price of land,
of course, has to be finite,
because if the old guy owned a
thing worth an infinite amount
of money,
he'd sell it and he'd buy
everything in the world.
So if you're going to have
equilibrium, there's no plot of
land that sells for 10,
for 100 trillion dollars.
The price of every plot of land
is some finite amount.
So if the land is producing,
I think it's sort of realistic.
Land is probably going to
produce forever.
As long as the world lasts,
if you've got land,
you'll get something out of it.
Someone will always want the
land, and so if it's going to
have a finite price,
the whole future dividends have
to be discounted to a finite
number.
If you put 0 in here for r,
you get infinity.
So this presence of land is
forcing the discount rate above
0.
So it's another argument that
Fisher never would have thought
of,
because he never thought about
infinities or anything like
that--
another argument for the real
interest rate being positive.
Okay, any other questions about
this?
So we reduce it to one
equation, and I'll put back the
p here in just one unknown.
Okay, = 5.
And we saw that we get p = .55.
And it's a quadratic equation,
so you can all solve quadratic
equations.
Okay, what else do I want to
say?
So now you could analyze all
sorts of things.
You could do the same
comparative statics Fisher does.
Suppose we change the utility
function and made this 1 third
instead of 1 half.
That would correspond to doing
what?
Making people more?
More what?
Impatient, okay.
And what would you think would
happen to the interest rate?
Student: Go up.
Prof: Go up, okay.
So in the Excel file,
we're going to do just that.
We're going to see it's going
to go up.
Instead, we could do the Social
Security thing,
and we could have every young
person give something to the
previous old,
which means everybody's
endowment goes from say 3 to 2
and 1 to 2,
so they get more in the future
and less early on.
So again, you could re-solve
for equilibrium and Fisher's
saying,
if you've got more endowment in
the future and less in the
present,
you're going to have a higher
real interest rate.
So you get a higher real
interest rate.
You could make the land more
productive and change this to a
2 everywhere,
and see what happened.
So in this Excel file,
I do that.
Maybe I'll come back to that.
So we're going to do those
experiments in a second,
but now I want to do two more
things before I end this.
The first is,
I want to say,
suppose we had growth in the
economy.
So what if you had growth?
Where am I going to add growth?
Over here.
I shouldn't have erased that.
So let's have growth.
What happens?
Well, Tobin,
you know, Yale's greatest
economist after Irving Fisher,
he said something which was 90
percent right but not 100
percent right.
He said, you know,
I pointed out to him that I got
these guys at Social Security.
I worked with them.
Anyway, these people at Social
Security and the Social Security
Administration calculated who
were the biggest beneficiaries
of Social Security,
and it was Tobin's generation,
the same generation as my
father.
And I said, "Look,
it's your fault that Social
Security is such a mess.
You benefited and I'm going to
have to pay for it."
And just like you're feeling
you're going to have to pay for
it, so it's even worse for you.
But even my generation's not
getting a very good deal.
Yours is getting a terrible
deal, Tobin's got a great deal.
And so he said to me,
it's not his fault,
it's my fault,
because I didn't have enough
children.
So the question is,
what happens if you--what does
that mean?
So what Tobin meant is that if,
instead of having 1 child for
every adult--
so every family has 2 children,
in other words,
instead of 1 child for every
adult,
so it goes 3,1,
3,1, 3,1, we start doubling--
the generations are growing
through time.
So since this is 30 years or
something, we could think of the
generations doubling.
That wouldn't be such a fast
growth rate.
And so Tobin might have meant,
if you double the generations,
you're going to have 6 and 2 as
the endowment.
2 guys at 3 and 1,
which means 6 and 2.
Then you're going to have 12
and 4.
It's going to be a gigantic
growth,
and so each generation,
when it's old,
the young guys,
if there's 6 and 2 here now--
I should use a different color.
If I wrote 6 and 2 here,
then each guy would have to--
or 2 guys at 3 and 1,
each (3,1) guy would only have
to give up half a unit,
because there'd be 2 of them
each giving half a unit to the
old guy.
And each one,
when he gets old,
getting a full unit.
So this guy would get a full
unit.
The next generation would only
give up half a unit,
and because there were 4 times
as many people in the next
generation,
each of them would still give 1
half,
making these 2 old guys get
their full 1.
And when they got old,
they'd similarly get a full 1
each of them.
So it would seem that if you
had a faster growing population,
then Social Security would be a
much better deal,
because the young would have to
give up less to the old and
still get fully paid back when
they were old,
and so Social Security wouldn't
have been a problem.
Ok, so why wasn't it our fault,
my fault--and your generation
is probably not going to have
any more children than my
generation.
Is that true, Tobin's argument?
Is it true that if we just had
enough children,
no one would have to lose out
in Social Security?
We could make the original
generation better off and also
every other generation after
that better off?
Yeah?
Student:
>
even giving up half to get 1
wouldn't
>
Prof: Right, exactly.
And so you can't know that
until you actually solve the
model.
So the point is,
that if the generations keep
growing like that,
the interest rate is going to
go up,
and so it's still going to be a
loss,
because although you're going
to be trading off - 1 half to
get 1,
as opposed to - 1 to get 1--so
this looks like a much better
scenario.
Once you get to this scenario,
there's going to be a bigger
interest rate.
So remember,
the present value of that trade
is - 1 (1 over (1 r)).
That's why it's negative,
because r is positive.
Here it's - 1 half (1 over (1
r)), but that's a different r.
That's an r,
I'll put it at the top,
that's in a new economy,
a growing economy,
and that r is going to be a
bigger r.
So even though it's - 1 half
instead of 1,
this thing's going to be small
enough, so you still end up
losing money.
But you'd never know that
unless you solved it.
And in fact,
it's still going to depend on a
little delicate assumption.
So Tobin, by the way,
never bothered to work this
out.
I claim that if you're going to
be doubling the population like
this,
there are going to be a lot
more people working on the land,
and so the dividends of the
land are probably going to grow
at the same rate.
So I would add a 2 here.
I'd make the dividends of the
land also double,
if the population doubled.
So the land dividends are going
to grow.
Now you can see why the
interest rate has to go up,
because the present value of
the land still has to be a
finite number,
the present discounted value of
the dividends.
And if the dividends are
growing, then the interest rate
had better be growing even
faster if you're going to make
that a finite number.
So sure enough,
when you solve it,
you're going to get a higher
interest rate.
So how would you solve it?
Let's say the growth rate is g,
so every generation is 1 g
times bigger the previous
generation.
So you could just change this
equation very simply.
What would you do?
Well, for any generation,
it's the same equation,
except that you've got 1 g
times as many old guys as you
have--these are young guys.
The number of young guys is 1 g
times the number of old guys.
So if it's generation t,
time t, this would be (1 g) to
the (t - 1), and this would get
multiplied by (1 g) to the t.
And the dividend,
5, so everybody's endowment is
also going up,
so it would be--actually I
screwed up.
It would be,
the old guy's 1 times (1 g) to
the (t-1) the young guys times
(1 g) to the t,
the dividend times (1 g) to the
t, or t - 1, whichever.
Okay, so that's the new
equation.
You can divide through by (1 g)
to the (t - 1).
So this is period t's market
clearing equation,
but you can see I
haven't--because the number of
old guys,
for each one of them that's
behaving like that,
but there are now this many of
them,
and the young guys are behaving
just as before,
but there are this many of
them, more of them.
And then the endowments of the
old have been grown that far,
you know, the old generation
has this many endowments.
The young has this much
endowments when young,
and then the land we also
assumed grew.
Okay, so now you can just
divide through by (1 g) to the
(t - 1),
and that goes away,
and that just leaves that,
and that goes away.
So you'd have that equation.
Student:
Can you do that again?
Prof: Oh no, yes.
I was afraid someone was going
to do that.
So let's just see where I got
this equation from.
So I took my original equation,
which didn't have any 1 gs in
it,
and I just said,
if I had growth in the economy,
it's no big deal to take that
into account.
I'm still going to have 1
equation, so I can still solve
it.
It's just that at every time t,
how many old guys do I have?
I have each old guy behaving
the same way as before,
except that now there's been a
growth of 1 g.
This is a generation before
this one, so this generation is
of size (1 g) to the (t - 1).
The young generation,
which was 1 generation ahead,
has grown by a factor of 1 g.
So there's (1 g) to the t of
these guys.
So I take their old demand,
you know,
the same for each guy,
but different number of guys,
and the young generation's
demand, and I have to set it =
to the supply.
But that's just the old guy's
endowment,
so 1 for each old guy,
and there are that many old
guys,
the young guys' endowment,
same as before,
and there are that many of
them, the land,
which I've also assumed has
been doubling,
1 g is 2.
So the land is also doubling.
And I'm not sure whether I
called this t or t - 1,
but either one,
it's not going to make a big
difference, okay?
Who asked the question?
You follow that, right?
I've got 1 gs everywhere,
so I can cancel a lot of them
out.
That's all I did.
So if I divide by (1 g) to the
(t - 1), I just get rid of the
(1 g) to the (t - 1)s.
I change (1 g) to the t divided
by (1 g) to the (t - 1).
That's just to the first power.
I got rid of this one.
I made this to the first power,
and this to the first power,
okay?
So I can solve that perfectly
easily and I'll do that in Excel
in a second.
And then we can see what
happens to everybody's utility.
So any questions about what I
did here?
Yes.
Student:
>
Prof: Yeah,
it's going to change the
answer, but it's going to
qualitatively be the same.
Student:
>
Prof: Well,
it depends whether when I do
this I want to say this is 2,
4,8, 16 or whether I want to
call it 1,2, 4,8,
16.
So I don't know which is the
right thing.
Probably I should have done
1,2, 4,8.
Probably the way I have it here
which is t - 1.
Okay, any other questions about
this?
So the last thing to do is to
just do it numerically,
because it's a pain to have to
solve these, you know,
these quadratic things.
It's only 1 equation,
but it's still a pain to solve,
and I happen to have written a
file that you can use to solve
these all automatically.
This doesn't look too good.
So the first one,
the first case I did,
suppose A, that's the exponent
for how patient you are.
That's half,
that's the first exponent,
half, half.
So I always can make the log
utilities, the 2 coefficients,
so it's A log B.
So I'm assuming utility here,
U of young and old is A log
young (1 - A) log old,
old consumption,
okay?
So A I took to be 1 half.
That's just what we were
figuring out.
I took the endowments when
young to be 3 and when old to be
1 and the land output to be 1
forever.
Then the price is what I'm
going to try and solve for,
and so I solved the market
clearing equation and cleared it
and did Excel solver and got the
consumption,
which we figured out was 1.775
when young and when old was
3.225,
which adds up,
the two of them add up to 5
together,
just as we thought.
And so I even calculated the
utility of each of the people.
I didn't do log utility,
actually, I wrote a monotonic
transformation.
I put Y to the A,
Z to the (1 - A).
It's easier for me,
you get positive numbers.
That's e to the U.
So I might as well describe
utility as the exponent of U.
Take e to it,
so it's a positive number.
When you do logs of small
numbers, you get negatives,
so that's easier to look at.
So that's the utility.
Okay, now we can do Social
Security.
What happens with Social
Security?
The only effect of Social
Security, remember,
it's the same model.
You just take stuff away from
the young and give it to the
old.
So nothing changes,
except the young's endowment
goes down to 2 and the old's
endowment goes up to 2.
And then the rest of the
model's exactly the same.
And so, of course,
it's going to give you a
different price.
p_A is different.
So p_A is smaller.
That means today's price of
next year's good is smaller.
There must be more discounting.
So I did the interest rate,
1 over 1 r = p,
so the inverse of p is this
thing.
So the forward rate is 161
percent, and if you think of
that as 30 years,
that's an annualized 3.2
percent interest rate.
Before, it was only a 2 percent
interest rate annualized,
right?
Remember we got the 1 r to be
181 percent, 1.81,
so r is 81 percent.
So this Social Security doubled
the interest rate from 81
percent to 161 percent.
Huge increase in the interest
rate, so Social Security has
raised the interest rate.
And so you re-solve the whole
equilibrium and it didn't crush
everybody, but everybody's
utility went down except for the
very first generation.
We know they won for free.
But now I could do the same
thing with growth.
I could just solve that
equation on the left,
and so I plug in now the growth
rate from generation to
generation, 1 growth,
and here I've got 2.
So it doubles every period,
just the example I did,
and so I solve it and you see
that of course from the
generations growing and land is
being more productive and there
are more apples and stuff like
that,
there's just more for everybody
to consume.
It's actually made everybody
better off.
But now we see that Tobin and
the interest rate is higher,
way higher, 247 percent instead
of 161 percent.
If I do now Social Security in
the growing economy,
every generation when young
only has to give up half an
apple and get 1 whole apple when
old,
so that raises the interest
rate from 247 percent to 300
percent,
annualized from 4 percent to
4.7 percent.
So the rate of growth is faster
now than the growth of the
economy, right?
This interest rate,
300 percent is faster than the
rate of growth,
which is 100 percent.
So again, everybody is going to
lose.
They're going to go from
3.06--they're still going to
lose by Social Security,
to go down to 3.
But Tobin, I would say,
is 90 percent right,
although more children doesn't
solve the Social Security
problem,
because it's going to increase
the rate of interest.
So you're still going to have
losers.
Nonetheless,
the loss is now much smaller
with lots of children than it
was before.
So Tobin, I would say,
is 90 percent right.
If only every generation would
have more children,
we still would have had a
crisis in Social Security.
We still would have had this
every generation complaining it
was getting a bad deal,
but it would be a lot less bad
than it was before.
And then I did this variant,
depending on what we said,
whether the growth was--whether
I had a g to the t or a g to the
(t - 1) there.
It doesn't really change that
much.
Okay, so that's it.
So you see, just by a very
simple modification of the
problem,
you can resolve--it's just
understanding is,
at least in my mind,
so much clearer now about what
role growth plays.
Having more children doesn't
make the problem go away.
It makes it better,
but you can never make it go
away, because the interest rate
is always going to be higher
than the rate of growth of the
economy.
So let's do one last experiment
on this stuff.
Another problem to resolve.
I wrote a paper,
the newspapers were saying the
same sorts of things and I'll
tell you what they were saying.
Oh no, I did a mistake.
Sorry.
Okay, so remember those
pictures that we showed before
of the stock market.
If you take out inflation,
the stock market seems to go in
these waves where prices go up
and then they come down,
then prices go up,
then they come down and prices
go up,
then they come down.
We've had 5 big waves of stock
markets going up and coming
down.
We're now in a period where
they've been coming down.
The stock market is lower now
than it was 10 years ago,
correcting for inflation.
In fact, even not correcting
for inflation.
So why would you expect that to
happen?
Is there any logic to that?
So here's an old picture of the
stock market.
I wrote this paper in 2005.
Remember at the first class,
we had a picture like that.
You can see the stock market
going up and down,
up and down,
five waves.
It's now come down further.
This is like 2001 or '02,
so it's come down way further
than that.
So is there any explanation for
why that would happen?
So here's an explanation I gave
in a paper, which a lot of
people in the newspapers were
giving.
I said, the baby boomers.
I said all these baby boomers
like me, we're getting old.
We're going to start selling
our stocks and so the stock
market's going to go down.
And so that's what newspapers
were saying too.
The difference is,
that the economists criticized
the newspapers and me and they
say, "Oh you're
crazy," they said.
"The stock market,
it can't be that the stock
market is going to go down,
and everybody knows it's going
to go down,
because if we knew it was going
to go down in the future,
it would have already gone down
now."
Okay, so you have to give an
argument.
So what I pointed out was that
if you look at the history of
live births, you get the same
cycle.
Look, it went up and down,
up and down.
I don't know if you can read
that.
I can hardly read it myself.
What years are these?
Why is it so unreadable?
Let's just see if I blow it up
a little bit.
Now I can see it.
This is 1910,
'20, '30, '40,
'50, '60, '70,
'80, '90,2000.
You can see these were live
births.
So births, there a baby boom
and then a plummet,
then another huge baby boom.
That's the famous baby boom,
my baby boom,
and then a plummet.
And then there was another baby
boom.
I forget what they call it,
the X generation or whatever it
is, some other baby boom that
happened.
Basically my baby boomers,
me having children,
another big baby boom and then
birth rates are going to go
down.
So I think that you are--the
number of 18 year olds in the
country is at its all time high,
or is going to be in two years
when my poor son tries to get
into college.
And so then it's going to go
down again.
So this is a cyclical thing
that keeps happening over and
over again with baby booms and
busts.
And everybody knows about the
baby boom after the war,
my generation,
the '50s and '60s when I was
born.
Everybody knows about that,
but they don't realize that
there's been baby boom after
baby boom after baby boom,
and this is a cyclical
phenomenon.
And then the thing that they
really don't know is that it's
exactly the same as the stock
market,
that those 5 patterns in the
stock market were the same
patterns of the baby boom.
Okay, so I'm going to end with
that picture.
Okay, so a picture is worth a
thousand words,
but it's not that compelling an
argument.
You need a little bit of
analytics.
Suppose everybody knew that
generations were going to get
bigger and then smaller and then
bigger and then smaller.
Would the stock market go up
and then down and then up and
then down, as I was saying,
and as all these newspaper
columnists were saying?
Or would it just stay the same,
as these less imaginative
economist critiquers were
saying, that it couldn't have
anything to do with demography?
Because by rationality,
people would look forward and
they'd anticipate it going down,
so they'd all sell before it
went down,
so it would never go down.
So it turns out that it does go
up and down,
and that argument the
economists gave doesn't make any
sense,
because they were implicitly
assuming that the rate of
interest stayed the same the
whole time.
And if the rate of interest
doesn't stay the same,
then there's no reason why the
stock market has to stay the
same.
So let's go back to where we
were before and change the model
a little bit.
Let's suppose that the model is
an alternation between big
generations and small
generations.
So let's suppose that you have
(6,2), (3,1),
and (6,2).
I think I kept--so it's a good
question.
What should I do with land?
I think I kept it at 1 every
period.
God, I hope that wasn't the key
to the result.
So in the paper,
of course, I had,
you know, people living 80
years and I had their income
reflecting the sort of trend in
income over the lifetime.
But anyway, for the purposes of
this class, let's say there's a
small generation where it goes
young 3, old 1.
Then the next generation,
which is just 2 guys,
so they're both (3,1) guys,
so in aggregate,
they're going to be (6,2).
The next generation's (3,1),
the next generation's (6,2),
the next generation's (3,1) and
it keeps alternating like that
forever.
Now, how would you solve for
equilibrium?
Does the whole thing just get
much more complicated?
I mean, what happens, after all?
Any questions here about what
we're doing?
So it looks way more
complicated, but it's not.
It's a little bit more
complicated, but not much.
You can still solve for this.
So I'm going to not spend too
much time on this,
but I'm just going to show you
what you would do.
So what would you do?
Well, by symmetry,
I claim, you can guess that
there are going to be two
prices.
So you notice that every
generation only cares about the
relative price when it's young
and when it's old.
So there's this relative price.
That relative price between
consumption at time 1 and time
2, that's going to affect the
generation born at time 1.
It actually has no effect on
any other generation.
These generations are born
after that, so this interest
rate, this relative price
between these two periods
affects only 1 generation.
So this generation is affected
by the interest rate between
time 2 and time 3.
This generation is affected by
the interest rate at time 3 and
time 4.
Every generation is responding
to the interest rates during its
life, not during another
generation's life.
So by symmetry,
I think, you can guess--
and it turns out to be
true--that there's going to be a
price,
a relative price--I should call
them small--
for the small generation,
and a relative price for the
big generation.
The same thing is going to
happen.
So this relative price will be
p_small,
this will be p_big.
Then we'll get
p_small again here,
and p_big connecting
these guys.
And it's just going to keep
repeating itself over and over
again.
And by symmetry,
you could guess that the
equilibrium would look like
that.
Is this making sense?
It's not making sense.
Is it making sense?
So what would I have to check
to see that there's equilibrium?
Let's do it over here.
Let's do a small generation.
Okay, so we never did the first.
So the first generation,
it depends whether we start
with a small one or a big one.
But remember,
if we can clear all the markets
for all time,
except the first market,
that one has to automatically
clear.
That was Walras' insight.
So we know that if we can clear
all these,
the first one's going to look
very different,
but it's going to clear anyway,
so I don't really have to worry
about it.
So we'll see why that works.
So I'm going to now talk about
market clearing at any time,
except the first one,
which is more complicated.
The first one seems really
complicated because there's this
guy 0 who owns these dividends
that go on forever.
But of course,
they're just worth the price of
land, which he's going to sell
off.
But anyway, we'll come back to
that in a second.
So in every generation,
every time period,
when small generation is young,
what do you get?
What's the market clearing
equation going to be?
Well, the small generation is
going to be young,
so that means the old
generation is big.
Sorry, it's a half-year,
so the big old guys,
their endowment is going to be
6.
There's 2 of them,
so I can put the 2 out here.
3 1 p_big,
divided by p_big,
that's the big old generation
and the young generation,
they're the usual 3 1
p_young,
divided by 1.
A has to = now,
how many endowments do we have?
We've got 2 old guys each
owning 1, so that's 2 times 1.
That's their endowment,
3, that's the young guys,
the land dividend.
So that's 6.
Student:
If you divide the second
>
small?
Prof: So this should be
p_small,
not p_young.
p_small.
No, I don't,
because the old guys--the big
generation is old.
The small generation is young.
So the young generation,
they're consuming in their
youth now, so they're looking at
their endowment.
The price when they're young is
1.
So their young endowment is 3,
their old endowment--
their income's 3 times the
price to them of 1 when they're
young,
plus the endowment of 1 when
they're old times
p_small,
divided by the price when
they're young,
which they're thinking of as 1,
right?
They only care about the
relative price between young and
old.
That relative price is
determined by p_small.
So I could call it
p_t and p_t
1, but I know that ratio
is going to be
p_small.
So really, it only depends on
the ratio, so I might as well
just use the ratio,
p_small.
This is a crucial idea that
I've used 100 times and I
think--
I've used it now 3 or 4 times
anyway--
so, but I think some of you
don't quite know what the hell
I'm talking about.
So somebody ask me a question
if they don't know why this is
right.
Whoever just asked it,
maybe you still don't know why
it's right.
Who asked this question a
minute ago?
Yes.
Do you understand how I got
this?
You do.
Okay, but when the old
guys--see, the old guys,
which is the big generation,
we're clearing time--we're
looking at this time.
So the total endowment is 3 for
the young generation.
Their endowment is 2,
and the 1 unit of land.
That's where I got the total
supply of 6.
So this generation when it's
young,
they care about the
p_small,
the relative price between here
and here,
and so they're looking at
p_small,
the relative price of 1 to
p_small.
The old generation at the same
time is looking over their
lifetime at the ratio of
consumption here to here,
which is given by
p_big.
So they've got a
p_big here,
and they're consuming when old,
so they're dividing by
p_big,
okay?
But now we've got a second
equation, which is when the big
generation is young.
So why don't you tell me what
that equation's going to be?
How much is the endowment when
the big generation is young?
That's, maybe,
clearing it this time.
Here the big generation is
young, so what's the endowment?
It's going to be the young--so
the old, there's only going to
be 1 old guy.
There are going to be 2 young
guys, each have endowment of 3,1
unit of land,
so that's 8.
You can see that adds up to 6 1
1 is 8.
Okay, and what's their demand?
What's the demand for the 2--so
there's the old.
What are the old going to be
doing here?
It's in this generation we're
doing the market clearing.
Somebody knows how to answer
this.
Yeah.
Student:
>
Prof: :
Over here, the young,
the small generation only has 1
when it's old.
Student: Big generation.
Prof: :
But big generation,
that's over here.
We're clearing at this time
period, so there's a bunch of
young guys and just a few old
guys.
So the endowments are 6 1 1.
The time is going that way,
so that's why that's an 8 over
here.
So if this is the 1 old guy's
endowment, 2 young guys who have
3 each, that's endowment of 6,
the land is 1,
so you get 8.
That's how I got an 8 over
there.
That's the supply.
So what's the demand?
Who's trying to buy the stuff?
What's the demand of the old
guys?
Student:
>
Prof: And that's going
to be what?
They're planning to spend when
they're old.
We're doing this one.
They make their plans when
they're young.
They anticipate what the prices
are going to be and so how much
do they plan to spend when
they're old?
Student:
1 half times 3 1p--
Prof: 3 1p what?
p what?
What p?
Student:
p_small.
Prof: p_small,
exactly.
Over p_small, plus
Student:
>
Prof: What are the young
guys doing?
We're over here.
So 2.
There are 2 of them.
What's this?
p what?
Divided by?
Oh, there's 1 half here.
Student:
>
Prof: 1.
Okay, exactly.
So that's it.
So there are 2 equations and 2
unknowns, p_big and
p_small,
and 2 equations.
So to solve this whole model,
you could get 2 equations--you
just have to solve these two
simultaneous equations,
which I did.
And then you can find the
effect.
So the economist critiquers
would say, "Well,
p_big should
equal--"
What would be the price of
land, by the way?
So what's the price of land
going to be in the end?
What's going to be the price of
land, according to Fisher,
at time 1?
At time 1, let's say.
So right here,
what's the price of land?
Remember, it's the price after
the dividend is paid,
so what's the price of land?
Student:
>
Prof: Let's do the
present value of the discounted
dividends.
What would it be?
Maybe I'd better write it over
here.
Remember, the dividends are
just 1 1--you know,
1 --so there's going to be 1 1
1 1, but I'm going to be
multiplying by something.
So what is the price of land?
p_small,
incidentally,
=--
I could always write that as 1
over 1 r_small and I
could write p_big as 1
over 1 r_big.
Okay, so what's the price of
land going to be?
So it's the price of land
starting here just after the
dividend is paid.
So it's hard to think about
this, but if you can figure this
out,
then you've totally understood
everything in the course,
because this is so much
more--it uses all the ideas in a
just way more complicated way.
Yes?
Student:
>
Prof: Well,
start telling me the formula.
So if I want--when I do the
first terms, what is this first
term?
Student:
>
Prof: So you would put 1
r_small here?
Okay, and now what would you
put over here?
Student:
1 r_big.
Prof: You'd put 1
r_big here?
Student:
>
Prof: Okay, very good.
So now you guys really know
what's going on.
What would you put over here?
Student:
>
Prof: Okay, exactly.
1 r_small time 1
r_big,
times 1 r_small.
Okay, that's that one.
I'm going to stop with that.
Too much.
dot, dot, dot.
So you have the idea now.
What's the idea?
You're taking the present value
of all the dividends.
So this dividend,
you have to discount it by 1
r_small.
This one, you have to discount
it twice.
First to bring it back here,
that's 1 r_big,
then to bring it back here,
that's another 1
r_small.
So 1 r_big,
1 r_small.
The third dividend,
you discount first at the small
discount, then at the big
discount, then at the small
discount, just like that.
You keep adding them.
So why should the prices--what
if you look at the price of land
at time 2?
Is it the same number as that?
Is it the same formula?
Student:
>
Prof: It's not the same
formula, because at time 2
you're starting here,
and the first discount is
p_big.
So it's going to be 1 over 1
r_big 1 over 1
r_big times 1
r_small 1 over 1
r_small times 1
r_big dot,
dot, dot.
So this isn't the same as that.
It would only be the same as
that if r_big was = to
r_small,
if p_small was equal
to p_big.
So which one do you think is
bigger?
Do you think p_small
is = to p_big,
or one of them is bigger than
the other, and why?
That's the answer to the
critics' puzzle.
So you see, you've taken
something that appeared in the
newspapers.
It sounds like common sense.
If there are all these
middle-aged people like me,
bidding up--you know,
there are so many of us who
want to hold stocks.
We're at the peak of our
earning power.
We've got tremendous amounts of
money.
What are we going to do with it
except put it into stocks.
You'd think common sense would
be the price of stocks would
have to go up.
When we get old and we're
selling all our stocks,
you'd think the price of stocks
would have to go down,
okay?
So that would tell you that the
interest rate was going to be
bigger or smaller.
So that would suggest that the
price at time 1,
when the small generation was
young, would be low,
and the price at time 2 would
be high.
And that could happen if this
interest rate was low,
and this interest rate was
high.
But does that happen or doesn't
that happen?
You can't know until you solve
in the model.
The critics said, "Oh,
that can't be right,
because somehow the price
should even out and everybody
should be looking ahead and
buying or selling at the right
time."
You can't buy and sell at the
right time, because you're going
to be dead.
So you don't have much choice,
except when you're young here
to save, and when you're old
here to dis-save.
They seem to have overlooked
that small problem.
So the point is that,
to know the answer,
you can't just reason it out
verbally.
You have to write down a model,
solve for the model and see
what happens.
And sure enough,
it happens--so we go back to
the paper now.
Okay, are there any questions
about this?
Okay, so all I did in this
spreadsheet is I wrote down
these 2 equations.
So you see that I've got the
young and the old are the same
half, half log utilities.
The small generation is 3,1,
the big generation is 6,2.
Land is always producing 1
every period and we get 2
different prices.
The price is called
p_A.
That's the A generation,
which is the small generation
and the B generation,
which is the big generation.
So you can see that
p_A is a very small
number when the generation is
small, and that means the
discount rate is very high.
So a high interest rate when
the generation is small,
and a low interest rate when
the generations are big.
So in the money making peak of
the big generation,
the real interest rate is
small, and so that means you're
not discounting very much,
and so the prices are very high
of land.
And so sure enough,
the price when the small
generation is young is 1.29,
and when the big generation is
young, it's 2.08,
vastly higher.
So it really is the case that
as the generations rise and
fall,
the interest rates rise and
fall and the price of land rises
and falls,
and everybody's rational,
anticipating everything.
So it really could be--I'm not
saying it's true,
because it could be a
coincidence that these things
all matched up,
but the fact is,
demography can have a big
effect on economic equilibrium
in the stock market.
And you can be an economist and
believe in demography.
You don't have to be a Marxist
or something to think demography
and fertility and all that stuff
is going to affect the economy.
For a long time,
economics tried to wall itself
off from other social sciences
and say,
"Oh, those fertility
people and,
you know, all those
touchy-feely people,
it's got nothing to do with the
real markets."
Well, it has a lot to do with
the real markets.
Okay, so one last thing,
would you rather be in the
small generation or the big
generation?
Student:
>
Prof: Of course,
the answer's there,
but tell me why.
Yeah?
Student: Small.
Prof: Okay,
that's correct.
So I'm screwed.
And so why is that?
Student:
>
Prof: It turned out to
be the utility of the--this is
the utility of the big
generation per person.
Of course, adding the two
people together,
it's bigger,
so per person it was this,
a lot less than the generation
of the utility of the small.
So why did that happen?
Why exactly is that happening?
So remember,
I'm distinguishing your peak.
I'm calling young your peak
earning years and old I'm
calling the stuff when you're
retired, I'm not earning very
much.
So why is it that a high
interest rate is good?
Yes.
Student:
It encourages consumption today
for the younger generation.
Prof: Well,
I think the point is,
if you're making money when
you're young,
and you've got a high interest
rate,
that means a high return.
So you can make a big return
through your life,
whereas my generation had a
very low return.
The return I'm getting now is
terrible.
It's negative.
The return I'm getting now is
just hideous.
But when my parents were young,
they were making an
astronomical return,
incredible rates of return.
And they were earning money in
their younger years and
investing it to save when they
were old and they were getting
incredibly high return.
There was nothing to do with my
money.
There are so many people like
me pouring money into the stock
market,
we're getting a very bad
return, and that's why it's not
so good to be part of a big
generation.
So other people had said the
same thing.
They said big generations have
to squeeze into the same houses,
so there's less housing stock,
or we build more houses,
the next generation comes
along, there are all these
houses built for them and there
are less of them,
so they get better houses.
Everything's better when you're
the small generation.
You're screwed as the big
generation and here's an example
of it.
Okay, so that's it for Social
Security.
All the things I wanted to say
about Social Security.
Now the exam,
as I say, you won't have to do
the two generations and all that
stuff on the exam.
But the first part about
solving for the .55,
that one you might have to do
something like that.
But anyway, the lesson that you
can have a controversy in the
newspapers with arguments on
both sides,
you never can figure out the
right answer till you write down
a model.
And the model can be very
simple, the kind of thing you
could do as an undergraduate.
That's the lesson I'm trying to
communicate.
All right, so from now on
though, we have to change gears
and I think the course gets a
lot more interesting,
okay.
But we needed all this
background basics to have the
logic of finance.
But finance is really nothing
without uncertainty.
If you don't know what's going
to happen tomorrow,
that's when the thing gets
interesting,
that's when you have to think
harder,
that's when people make
mistakes, that's when a hedge
fund can make a profit,
that's when everything gets
more exciting,
when there's uncertainty,
and we have to start adding
uncertainty to our thinking
about the world.
So since I only have a few
minutes,
I'm going to spend the last few
minutes just reminding you of
what you're supposed to know
about uncertainty,
which is this slide, okay?
So it's not a very complicated
thing.
Where's the--I see PowerPoint.
Okay so there are two kinds of
uncertainty, one of which we're
never going to get to.
So the uncertainty that we're
going to work with in this
course is everybody understands
what could possibly happen.
So this was a brilliant states
of the world model,
it's called.
So Leibniz is supposed--see,
it says states of the world
right there.
Leibniz was the one who first
invented the idea of states of
the world.
He said, "We live in the
best of all possible
worlds."
So if you don't know what's
going to happen in the future,
we're going to represent that
as many potential states of the
world.
Now there are other ways you
could model uncertainty,
and it's a big subject in
epistemology and philosophy.
I'm going to stay--hew closely
to the states of the world
thing.
So if there's something about
the world we don't know
tomorrow,
I'm not going to assume that
it's just vague in our minds and
we can't quite make it out.
I'm going to assume you
actually can make it out.
It's just you don't know which
of the possibilities are going
to happen.
So it's many states of the
world.
So an example of that,
of course, is spinning a dice,
or spinning two dice,
so you don't know which of 36
possibilities is going to
happen.
Each of those would be one
state of the world.
Okay, so those are all the
possible sums,
so there are more states of the
world than there are outcomes,
notice.
You can get 2 through 12,
is the sum of the dice,
but there's still 36 possible
states of the world.
And so that random variable,
the sum of the two dice,
is expressed as a function.
It says, in every state of the
world, what is the random
variable's value?
So our state of the world,
by that I mean something that's
so detailed that it tells you
the value of every random
variable.
So that's how I'm going to be
thinking of uncertainty,
that we're here today and a
bunch of different things could
happen tomorrow,
and this is an exhaustive list
of everything that can happen
tomorrow.
We're going to have to come
back and criticize this
assumption, but it introduces
uncertainty in a way which is
still quantifiable and not
vague.
So you can talk about the
histograms of outcomes of the
dice, you know,
how many ways,
what are the chances of getting
a 7,6 out of 36,
etc.
So this is stuff I'm sure you
all know, okay.
The most famous histogram of
mathematics is the normal
distribution,
which I don't have time to
explain.
And so a normal distribution,
remember, is this exponential
thing.
The dice example,
you know, sort of looks like
it.
In fact, if you had enough
dice, and you kept averaging
their outcome,
it would be normally
distributed.
So lots of things turn out to
be normal.
One of the properties of normal
is that the tail gets small very
quickly, and so you're not going
to get very many outliers.
The normal distribution is a
very common distribution.
There're lots of reasons why it
should occur all the time,
and it's also mathematically
very easy to work with.
So economists for a long time
assumed that everything was
normally distributed,
but an implication,
as I say, of normal
distribution is that it's very
unlikely something extreme is
going to happen,
because this thing goes down
exponentially fast to 0,
so you're almost never going to
see something way out here.
Yet we get these crashes fairly
frequently.
Every 10,20,
30 years or something,
there's some gigantic outlier.
So clearly things can't be
normally distributed,
and that's called fat tails.
I'm sure you've heard about
that in the newspaper.
We're going to come back to
that.
Now there are a couple of
things that you need to--
so you can represent the payoff
of any random variable as a
picture,
and every state,
what is its payoff?
So a riskless random variable,
riskless investment,
will pay the same amount in
every state.
I still have a few minutes here.
Okay, so now two incredibly
important concepts,
which I'm sure you know--or at
least the mean you know--just
the average, what's the expected
payoff?
So the expected payoff is,
you multiply the outcome in
every state by the probability
of the state and you add it up.
Okay, so there are how many
different ways?
So if you have 1 dice,
you can figure out the
expectation of 1 dice.
It's equally likely to get 1,2,
3,4, 5 or 6,
and so if you add all those up,
multiplied by a sixth,
you get 3 and 1 half.
So the expectation of 1 dice is
3 and 1 half.
The expectation of two dice is
therefore--okay,
that's 1 dice.
Okay, now the expectation of
adding 2 dice together is of
course going to be 7,
because the expectation of 1
dice is 3 and 1 half and the
other dice is 3 and 1 half,
and so the expectation of the
sum is the sum of the
expectation,
so it's 7.
Okay, so you know that.
Now one more thing that you
have to know is the variance.
So how do you measure how
uncertain you are about what's
going to happen?
Well, the simplest number to
do, like with the dice,
is to say, the expectation is 3
and 1 half.
When we don't get 3 and 1 half,
it means there is some error.
Expectation wasn't confirmed.
So you could just measure the
error as the distance between 3
and 1 half and what you actually
got.
So if you got a 4 you could say
you were off by 1 half.
But people don't do that.
They measure the square of the
distance and they take the
average square of the distance,
and that's called the variance.
So if you got 4 when you were
expecting 3 and 1 half,
the error is 1 half squared,
so you take 1 sixth times 1
half squared,
1 sixth times 1 and 1 half
squared,
1 sixth times 2 and 1 half
squared.
That's for the high mistakes.
And the low mistakes,
you'd take 1 half times 1 half
squared,
1 half times 1 and 1 half
squared, plus 1 half time 2 and
1 half squared [correction:
1 sixth times each error,
not 1 half].
Now why do they use the
expected squared error instead
of just the expected error?
Well, for this simple reason,
which you may not have thought
of: if you had to guess--
if you looked at the error as
the penalty for making a wrong
guess,
and you were forced at the
beginning to say,
"What guess would you like
to make for how the dice is
going to turn out--
how the dice is going to turn
out and if you're wrong,
we'll penalize you by this
measure of error?"
Well, if you were just taking
the absolute error,
your best guess would be any
number between 3 and 4.
You could say 3 and 1 half,
but you could also say 3 and 1
quarter,
because if you said 3 and 1
you'd become closer on all the
low rolls of the dice,
and be a little further off on
all the high rolls,
and you'd get exactly the same
error.
So you could say any number
between 3 and 4.
But if you make the error the
square of the mistake,
your best guess is always to
say the expectation.
3 and 1 half is the only thing
you can say to minimize your
expected penalty,
if the penalty is the squared
error.
So because of that--so that's
connected to a mathematical
thing and orthogonal vectors and
all that.
Because of that,
the error we talk about always
is the squared error.
And so that's whenever we're
measuring uncertainty,
we're going to talk about the
squared error,
the average of the squared
errors--or the square root of
that,
which is called the standard
deviation.
Okay, I've one more minute to
just finish this.
I'm assuming you all know that
or can learn that.
One more thing,
I'm going to assume you know,
the last thing is the
covariance.
What does it mean to say that
random variables X and Y move in
the same direction?
So this was quite a brilliant
thought.
So what it means is that to
move in the same direction,
means if X surprises you by
being above what you would have
expected,
so if the expectation of X is X
bar,
and the expectation of Y is Y
bar, if you multiply the 2 and
they're both higher than you
expected,
you'll get a positive number.
If they're both lower than
expected, you'll also get a
positive number.
So by taking this sum,
the expected deviation from the
expectation,
multiplied, you get a number
which,
when it's very positive,
it means they're either both
positive together or both
negative together.
So they're going in the same
direction.
If one of them is above the
average while the other one's
below the average,
then you'll get a negative
number.
So big covariance means they
move in the same direction.
Big negative covariance means
they move in the negative
direction.
Okay, so I'm going to take it
for granted you know this,
and we're going to take this
up, starting right after the
exam, which is on Tuesday.